this is a story i was i wasn't going to
get into
because this is not exactly a tabloid
show you know this is not hollywood all
access or anything like that but this
story actually gets to something pretty
important in our politics and culture
i'm talking about yeezy i'm talking
about mr yay talking about the breakup
of kim yay
kim kardashian now dating pete davidson
why i don't know pete davidson pulls
above his weight in the girls i guess
but they're dating kanye was dating some
other girl i guess he's not dating her
anymore
it's very sad their marriage was falling
apart but he's still trying to get back
together
kanye west has been going after his
wife's
they're not actually divorced i don't
think he says his wife's
current boyfriend p davidson
he uh i won't he's using colorful
language but he posted a picture of pete
davidson who because he got a hillary
clinton tattoo on himself and he said
look at this d-i-c-k head i wonder if
instagram gonna shut down my page for
dissing hillary clinton's ex-boyfriend
then he goes on uh he keeps posting
pictures of pete davidson and going
after him
he says when i tag people i'm just
putting together the web they're a group
of people who run the media in the
election thank god for free speech so
kanye totally totally right on that
point
and uh then
pete davidson apparently sent kanye west
a message and said i'd never get in the
way of your children how you guys want
to raise your kids is
your business and not mine i do hope
that one day
i can meet them and we can all be
friends
right hey this is the new boyfriend
saying this to the husband
of the woman that he's dating
and kanye just responds all caps he says
no you will never meet my children
awesome i love that
i love that
we should all learn a lesson from kanye
right now i know that is a
not not necessarily the sort of thing
one would naturally think but kanye is
actually doing something right here
kanye is trying to save his marriage and
he's not just going along with this and
his wife kim kardashian has a whole
spread in vogue about how she's going to
live for herself now remember we covered
it on the show last week she's in her
40s it's about what she wants and she's
not going to let other people tell her
what to do and you know it's fine if her
children are traumatized by her leaving
her husband and by the dissolution of
their marriage and her
engaging in this high profile
fling with this hollywood derelict yeah
that's fine because it's for her it's
about me now and kanye west is saying no
i'm not going quietly i'm not doing this
i'm not going to let you have
your own
new life and take my children away from
me
and i'm not going to
pretend that it's all fine and it's all
amicable and it's all good and don't
worry you do you and i'll do me and
we'll just date whoever we want and by
the way when we get tired of those
people we're going to kick them out too
and we're going to date other people and
if our kids are extremely confused and
traumatized by that well that look
that's just that's just the cost of
pursuing your own appetites and desires
and now we can all be friends hey let's
all get dinner me you and pete davidson
and pete davidson's girlfriend pete
davidson's girlfriend's boyfriend it's
cool it's all good right no kanye's
saying no it's not good stop acting like
a harlot and a trollop and come back to
your husband and we're going to live
together because we made it an agreement
to do this we made a
consequ a consecrated marriage
vow before the people
of our community and before the public
and before our god and we're gonna honor
that
i love it
i love i don't know if it's gonna work
but i love it that's totally the right
attitude
it's totally the right the kim the kim
attitude of i'm just going to do me
don't let people tell you what to do i'm
going to do me and the kanye attitude of
no i'm going to do what i said i would
do and i'm going to live up to even
though i'm a extremely broken flawed
sinful person i am going to try to be
virtuous and holy and
it it that's not just you do you and
i'll do me and no we're we're going to
do what we should do and what we're
supposed to do
and we're going to defend if we're going
to have a good life and a good country
and a good society we're going to defend
the basic political institution the
family marriage
and
and i'm not going to let some scruffy
hair derelict from saturday night live
get in the way of that
absolutely right stand up kanye kim
should go back to her husband
we should we should
we should tighten up these sorts of
things i'm glad you like that clip ring
the bell please
you will get the notifications if you
don't get the notifications subscribe
over at apple podcast spot if i stitch
your google play wherever you get your
audio podcasts type in
the michael knull show subscribe leave a
five star review we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you